he fled as president of sri lanka but
returned on friday with nowhere to go
gotabe rajpaksa flew back nearly two
months after he fled angry protesters
who blamed him for pushing the country
towards economic collapse
he resigned while he was abroad
dozens of mps from his governing slppp
party were at the airport to welcome him
those involved in the protest that led
to rajapaksa's exit like manjula
samarasacra say he has the right as a
citizen to return but we strongly
believe that he
he is responsible for the crime crime a
lot of times as well as
regarding putting up this country to the
situation that we are in right now so
first here there has to be a
fast-tracked uh
investigation into the issues that he
has created and he has to come to the
legal system he has to face the legal
system the former president has moved
into this government residence
senior security sources have told al
jazeera his wish to move back to his
private residence in a colombo suburb
was denied because of security concerns
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
two years into his term
protesters blamed him and his government
for mismanagement bad decisions and
corruption that drove sri lanka to its
worst economic crisis in memory it's
incumbent therefore upon the government
to ensure that there is accountability
in place with regard to gotham rajapaksa
and apart from that he can
live a normal life i presume although of
course you know can he get about
can he be seen around in public is a
question that he'll have to decide
rajapaksa loyalists say it's too early
to indicate what the former president
will do now that he's back in the
country
after nearly two months of trying to
find a place to settle the former
president seems to have run out of
options having swept to power with
unprecedented popularity gotaber
rajapaksa has found out the hard way
that being a wartime leader doesn't
always guarantee success in peacetime
mineral
al jazeera colombo